they say it will be a street by street
cleanup strategy police fighting a crime
wave in lima a city of nearly 10 million
people on friday night they closed
several blocks of a street lined with
bars in one of the city's most dangerous
districts as part of the state of
emergency
the neighborhood councils call us and
tell us who are incurring in offenses we
are working with that information
dozens of armed robberies recorded by
security cameras in recent months have
many peruvians particularly women living
in fear margarita moya says she's been
forced to adapt
i don't go on the street after 5 pm i've
been assaulted many times they take your
wallet and phone and now if i have to go
out i don't have anything in my purse
the most common attacks young men
targeting backpacks and purses or men on
motorcycles stealing cell phones from
their victims pedus telecommunications
regulator says an average of 4 000 cell
phones are stolen every day around the
country
the national institute of statistics
says more than a quarter of lima's
population have been crime victims
more than 80 percent of the people who
live in the state of emergency zone say
they are dissatisfied with police
security but for the police it is
difficult for instance in this area
where more than 800 thousand people live
there's only 10 police cars to patrol
the streets
now the government has ordered the army
to join the patrols and with a clenched
fist says defense minister jose luis
gavidia
we'll use the full force of the law our
soldiers know what they need to do we're
armed forces and we go out with guns
authorities respected and that principle
must be recovered
some analysts say the government lacks a
considered plan to combat crime
effectively
instead of deterring the armed forces
may encourage organized crime actors to
arm themselves like in brazil or mexico
although we have an increasing level of
violence we are not in a critical
situation my impression is that the
government's measure is basically
populist the coronavirus pandemic has
left more than four million peruvians
without a job and police say most people
involved in criminal activity are young
unemployed men
sixty percent of peruvians disapprove of
president pedro castillo's six-month
long government for a range of reasons
including the crime rate
critics say more police and soldiers on
the streets even if effective will do
little to curb public discontent mariana
sanchez al jazeera lima peru